in this video I'm going to talk about my
theory of dementia blood pressure and
stroke now this is just for information
for you to go do more research I'm not
telling you that this is accepted in
traditional medicine I'm not telling you
that this is the cure I'm just giving
you information so you can do your own
research with your doctors help okay so
this is my theory there's a lot of
unknowns about dementia but there's an
interesting associating factor and that
is the build-up of calcium in the
arteries of the brain also it is a known
fact that if your arteries are filled
with calcium plaquing the arteries get
hard and the blood pressure goes up so
that's a big cause because if you look
at one of the medications for blood
pressure it's calcium channel blockers
what are calcium channel blockers there
are medications that lower and block
calcium interesting even magnesium is
known to help blood pressure why because
it lowers calcium strokes vascular blood
flow to the brain if you clog up the
arteries of the brain with calcium
plaquing which a lot of times they find
associated calcium but they're not
associated in the calcium is the thing
that's keeping the arteries from being
elastic in the brain and clogging up the
blood flow to the brain and craning
aneurysms so you can also have injuries
and other things but the point is that I
believe that the calcium is that is a
primary cause of allow these problems
just my theory on them but very little
attention is is put on lowering calcium
in the body isn't it it's like what do
people tell you to do take calcium
they're in a recent trial of many many
women postmenopausal they found that
women intake calcium for bone loss
increase their chance of heart attacks
by two times so again it's because the
calcium plugs up the arteries makes them
hard and there's no elasticity so the
pressure goes up so all this attention
is is put on one thing to lower your
fats right lower your fats lower your
cholesterol but guess what there are two
vitamins
there's more but there's primarily two
vitamins that control the transportation
of calcium through the body one is
vitamin d3 and one is vitamin k2 vitamin
d3 will increase the absorption of
calcium in these small intestines by 22
X so that pulls the calcium into the
intestine the vitamin k2 takes that
calcium from the soft tissues and pulls
it into the bone so k2 ism is the main
vitamin that cleans up the arteries of
calcium the soft tissues including the
joints the eyes the kidneys the prostate
the liver I mean think about how many
conditions occur with calcium first of
all when you get older you become stiff
that's in the joints you can have it on
the eyes as cataracts and the joints as
arthritis bursitis tendinitis kidneys a
kidney stone gall bladders golf stones
and there's a lot of other calcification
in the breasts so one of the new tests
that they're doing as probably a better
predictor for heart attacks would be a
calcium scan of the body in the arteries
and the coronary arteries in your heart
so again there's a lot of attention
being now shifted to calcium but not a
lot of attention putting on the fat
soluble vitamins that transport calcium
lots of people when they take k2 they
start cleaning up the calcium they feel
the bottom of their teeth start becoming
really like pearly whites because it
cleans all that calcium which is
basically the tartar so in deficiencies
of kk2
you get tartar on teeth heart attacks
strokes kidney problems stiffness that's
just because the calcium is not
transported so where do you get vitamin
k2 that's a big question it's a fat
soluble vitamin and you get it from
grass-fed beef grass-fed butter grasp it
whole milk yogurt it's in the fat the
exact thing that everyone's telling you
to avoid for these three conditions it's
the thing that people need
it's in the saturated fats it's not in
the unsaturated fats grass-fed beef
butter eggs and beef and Jan cheese if
you if you take I mean what do people
tell you to do they tell you to avoid
red meat if you are going to have red
meat have lean red meat if you go the
grocery store look at all the yogurts
it's hard to find a whole milk yogurt
it's all low-fat or no fat well that's
exactly what you need to start consume
if you want vitamin k2 so I believe that
this is the reason why the calcium is
not transported through the body and it
makes sense because it's date
coincidence with the complete fear of
consuming fats all right so I will put
down below some ideas on what you can
play around with with dosages of vitamin
k2 and D and some eating principles but
you no longer have to be afraid of
saturated fats especially if you are
consuming the right ones from grass-fed
you know butter and cheese and eggs
something like that the only other thing
that you want to look at is the amount
of digestive juices that help digest
these fats and vitamins and that comes
through the gallbladder and there's
something called bile B il that helps
absorb it so I'm not saying to go crazy
and start eating all this fat I'm just
saying that you want to consume some of
it and if you have a hard time digesting
it it could be because either you you
don't have enough bile because you're
not used to digesting the fats or are
you missing a gallbladder in which case
you need to take some bile salts to put
that back in to emulsify and break down
and absorb these fat fiber vitamins so
again I believe this is the link that's
been missing and if someone's taking
this it doesn't work you have to look at
the ability to digest fats and that
would be the gallbladder and I create a
lot of videos on that but I just want to
kind of give you that connection as a
root cause and the play route that talk
to your doctor see if it can help you
alright so that's the summary of my
theory and dimension blood pressure and
stroke and I will see you
next video